Hello and Merry Christmas. My name is Larry Arnn.
I work at Hillsdale College, and this
is the most important being on earth.
Her name is Charlotte, or we call her The
Squink, and she is our first grandchild.
She seems a good thing to have around
here in a Christmas message because
the Christmas message is about a baby, and
every baby represents something like Christmas
because babies are small, and yet everyone knows
they're of infinite value, certainly this one is.
Yes, so true. Think about the
Nativity story. Did you have to memorize
Bible passages when you were young? I
did. Look at that, the star has fallen.
I had to memorize the Luke account of the
Nativity and I can remember most of it:  "And there
were in the same country shepherds abiding
in the field watching their flocks by night.
And the angel of the Lord came upon them, and the glory of
the Lord shone about them..." —and this is the part I
like— "...and they were sore afraid." So, what were they
afraid about and what did the angel come to say?
This baby had been born, and the news of the baby
was so shocking that Herod killed many babies to
make sure he got that one killed because that one
was going to challenge his rule. Well that one did
challenge his rule, and the rule of every tyrant
in history because the Christmas message is,
nobody except God can have absolute power, and
nobody but God deserves it.  It's a very turbulent
world right now. Our College is thriving. I
think that's because of help from people like
you, but I think that's because we, together,
we remember that there are eternal things,
and one of the finest happened at Christmas, when
a baby was born. Thank you, and Merry Christmas.